Now I'm going to talk
about setting goals.
You probably have some personal
goals for yourself like getting fit.
Well, you can also set goals for
your app.
For example, you might set a goal for
users to click the donate button or
reach a certain level in the game.
Or stay engaged with the app for
a certain amount of time,
hopefully not that long.
To set goals for
the app you go to the Admin interface.
And then in the View, you click Goals.
And then create New Goal.
When you're setting up a goal
you'll see a list of templates.
If you choose a template,
it fills in the name and the type for
you, like this.
But even if you choose a template,
you can change the name and type anyway.
So I'm going to start out
by creating a custom goal.
And you enter whatever name you want and
then you choose a type of goal.
So you can specify screen that
you want the users to reach or
duration how long you want them
to stay engaged with your app.
You can specify how many screens you
want them to visit in a session.
And you can also specify an event
like view product or show recipe.
So I'm going for
five screens per session min.
So after you set the name and the type,
you can add more detail for the goals.
The details you can set depend
on the type of the goal.
If the type is number
of screens per session,
well you choose how many you want.
I want at least five,
that would be greater than four.
If the type is duration, then you could
specify criteria for the duration.
How many hours, minutes,
seconds do you want the users
to stay engaged as a minimum.
If the goal type is destination,
then you specify the screen name.
And as you see, there' some flexibility
around how you specify the screen name.
You can give a regular
expression if you want.
And notice the funnel option.
If you enable this, you can specify
the progression through your app
that you wont use to take
to reach the destination.
My advice is to start out with
the simpler options and as you
build your understanding of Analytics,
to add in more complex tracking.
For now, I'm not going to set a funnel.
If the goal type is event,
then you specify the category,
the action, the label and
the value of the event.
And actually you can specify any or
all of these starting with the category.
You could just set the category.
And leave the other values
blank if you wanted.
So I'm going to set up a goal
called five screen for
my users to visit five
screens per session.
So I've chosen the type
Pages/Screens per session.
And I want them to go to at least five.
So that would be greater than four.
Then, I create the goal.
So now my goal is listed
in the list of goals.
Now you might be wondering,
do you need to write code for the goals?
Well, it depends, is order activity
tracking enabled for your app?
If it is, then you don't need to write
any code for screen-related goals.
Analytics will get hits for
all screen views.
But if the goal depends
on other kinds of hits,
such as event hits, then your app must
include the code to send those hits.
If auto activity
tracking is not enabled,
then your app must have the code to send
the hits that Analytics needs to figure
out if the goals are met, or not.
And that includes screen view hits,
because if auto activity tracking's not
enabled, Analytics won't
get screen view hits.
Other than the ones that get
explicitly sent by the app.
So I've created one goal for
my app so far.
But each app has a limit to
how many goals it can have.
After you create a goal,
you can't delete it.
There's no point in hunting around for
the delete button,
because it isn't there.
However, you can edit an existing
goal and change it completely.
So I'm going to change my goal.
My new goal is for users to read
the recipe for dinner suggestion.
There are two ways to express this goal.
Either I can set a goal for
users to click the Show Recipe button,
or I can set a goal for users to go to
the show recipe activity or screen.
So I'm going to set a goal for my users
to go to show recipe as a destination.
Now, my app sends a screen view hit
through the code in the on start method
of the show recipe activity.
So I need to make sure
that the screen name and
the goal is the same as the one
that gets set in the code.
And see here how it says verify this
goal, you can click on this to see
what the conversion rate would have been
for the date of the past seven days.
So this is only going to be helpful if
you actually have a bunch of data from
the past seven days.
And it has to be exactly the past
seven days, but not including today.
So now I'm going to save my goal,
and there it is.
Now my app already sends a screen view
hit for the Show Recipe activity, so
Idon't need to make any
changes in my code.
So I already have the app
running on the phone, and
I didn't even need to redeploy it.
I'm just going to go ahead and
show the recipe a few times.
And then I'm going to
need to wait a while for
the goals to show up in
the Analytics dashboard.
The real-time view in Analytics
doesn't show goal conversion,
so you may need to wait a while for
the goals to show up.